it's clinton
jones he's back with us for another show
it's ran white man he's back with us for
another show
yeah and you've got me jake with you
guys again
for another show
and we may have christian comment from
time to time
but he doesn't have a video so don't ask
why you don't see him
all right guys son welcome back
how's it going guys clint how you doing
oh man
how are you feeling i'm tired i'm tired
are you tired
why are you beat up did you get jumped
in an alley
no not quite not quite again okay
now i've been i've been waking up super
early i'm on a really early schedule
and um it's been good yeah yeah it's
been great are you actually legit
getting up at 5 am
5 45 to get started at 6. what are you
doing
um the first 20 minutes is a workout so
you got to get a sweat on
the second 20 minutes is you like roll
out of your bed it's 5 45
and it's just like right into sit ups
like that's it
not quite 605 in one second you move on
to the next thing
no no so 5 45 6. yeah
wake up and get ready for the workout
okay exactly so
i wake up and then like um i like that
basically just
that's what my dad said about it yeah
he's like
he's like you know you know isn't he's
like in the batman comic books he'd get
out of bed and just do push-ups like
immediately i was like
i'm not at that level yet but yeah yeah
i started with
20 minutes of a workout and then um it's
another 20 minutes of just like
either like meditation or yoga or
like scheduling your day so just
journaling about yesterday and
what you want to do today and then the
last 20 minutes is
learning something so i've been reading
uh this rich dad poor dad book and
trying to
figure out finances and you know that
that difficult difficult topic of
finances what's there to figure out you
just go out to your tree where the money
grows on and you just pluck the dollar
bills off
and continue your day
i wish i wish so you know i also got up
at 6 am today
by choice no so
let's let's jump in for a little bit of
story time real quick so my wife jenna
is a nurse and she leaves the house at
six a.m
i didn't realize all that this morning
at 6 00 a.m i hear the door close
like very distinct door closing in the
other room and i'm immediate i was like
instantly awake jenna's next to me here
and i'm like all right jenna's there the
dogs are in here
someone is in our house and i
immediately sit up and i'm like jenna
wake up wake up
she's not waking up like we're about to
get
murdered in our own house and that's
when i realized she had put like pillows
and stuff underneath the covers so it
looked
like she was still in bed and pulled me
for
several seconds i figured it out pretty
quickly but it was still like
i was awake i was like
like adrenaline rushing through my body
at six in the morning
and she had no idea because she's like
i'm going to work to you know heal
people
she was probably trying to do something
nice to be like oh ren's so sound asleep
i'll put these pillows here and it'll
make him feel still feel like i'm there
i don't think she intended any of that
because she likes to put like pillows
between her legs for her hips or
whatever i don't know
girl stuff right and but i think she had
enough pillows that like i
i was literally full because i remember
looking at her it was still kind of dark
at 6am
i remember looking at where she would be
in the bed and it was like that's a body
there's a person there
don't even think about it she's still
here oh that's so scary
[Laughter]
that's so sketchy that's oh dude i mean
i i did get you with those uh with those
hard drives when i pretended to drop all
those hard drives
and i had you for like a solid like 20
seconds
and you had to sit down on the couch and
like oh my goodness
so that's an upcoming crew video where
we're actually redoing some old
uh vfx or maybe by this point this video
is out i don't know when this podcast is
dropping
but it involved us going through a bunch
of old hard drives
and these are like the archive like we
had to take them out of the ground with
a little
toothbrush and wipe off all the extra
features
we spent the last hours pulling them out
and plugging them in and figuring out
which ones we needed and we had to
assemble like
six of them to get because it was on
raid six and we had to assemble
yeah you're you're like i got all of
these hard drives these are the ones we
need for this project
and you took a step and then tripped and
all of the hard drives that
flew out of your hand and clashed on the
ground i was like
no and you're like oh no what have i
done
i was like this is it we have just lost
years worth of information
and then clinton like
[Laughter]
he just looked at me and i was like oh
you sort of
what i just sat down and i had to like
had to gather myself cause you got me
you got me good
what did you guys have to do that for we
were trying to well for a crew video
we're trying to redo
we're trying to remaster some of the old
corridor videos
yeah yeah so we had to find the original
footage and we were trying to find
the actual project files with the vfx on
it right um
okay and we thought we were onto it like
we were an hour
into this like case we were solving this
case it was it was like national
treasure
and um we had to pull all six drives
because it was on raid six
and eventually we found we found them
all and as we were plugging them in
that's what i i like just got empty
cases and i just switched them out
oh yeah important note there were no
hard drives inside these cases they
resemble
uh the cases resemble like uh what do
you call those those lighters the zippo
like
yeah yeah where it's like the whole top
just kind of like rotates open yeah and
then you put the hard drive in
but we had all these cases because we
had been taking all the hard drives out
of them and i thought he had already put
them all back in
yeah so i recently learned that if you
just let hard drives sit
sometimes they will naturally lose data
uh yeah like if they're traditional disk
drives
um shoot yeah so we've i just like
i literally just learned this like a
month ago
and so now i'm like oh god because our
entire
archive from like 2015 before
is gone no it's not gone
yeah it is jake wait what really
are you breaking news huge asterisk it
is oh
kind of not gone i mean we have the
videos
the project files aren't that important
it's all about the final like high res
there were a couple hard drives that
straight up didn't work
is there raw footage no
yeah no yes yes for glitch okay footage
there is raw footage
but it's like and i knew going into this
i was like i'm pretty sure
none of these project files still exist
for this project i'm like oh let's go
find them
open up the vfx folder empty yeah yeah i
remember
we deleted those i think i remember
um okay but the the i think that the
final thing we did was like
we'll save the high res render and we'll
save the
youtube render and then we'll save the
raw footage
i think that's that's what we ended up
agreeing on for a lot of those projects
which i don't really know why i don't
know why
either it's like i guess we can do all
the work and recreate it
if we want no there's no way we never
i don't know i mean hey that's what
we're doing i guess that's exactly what
we're doing right now we're trying
the idea is that we were going to open
up the original after effects file
and load it up onto an old computer and
the brand new computer which this video
is about
and see like how fast each video renders
that same project file
but there was no after effects file
there was no there's no files period
effects files there were there was the
original footage and so through that we
were able to like
get the original shot that uh so peter's
been working on that shot
um so i think what we need to do
eventually
maybe next year is put that on a tape
drive
i think that's if it's not in progress i
think it's been brought up
yeah we've brought they brought it up
it's just it's a little it's a little
cost prohibitive right now
like it's kind of worth more than it
costs more than it's really worth but
right i know every time i talk to
spencer he's like oh
yeah tape drives we're like right drives
i'd say we're like
we're like six to eighteen months away
from what about being ssds
our ssds just gonna like so
all hard drives do have a lifespan or
after a certain amount of time
just like the the actual like atoms
themselves
lose integrity yeah and like i i don't i
don't know
exactly how it stores these bits and
bytes but niko is describing it as
for the for the tape not the tape drives
the disk drives you know like the 5400
and the 7200 rpm
drives
one of these drives yeah i just happen
to have one sitting here
um they over time uh the magnetic
uh discs inside uh because it's only a
zero or a one sometimes
they can flip polarity i'm sure i'm
getting some of this wrong
but the idea is that like if over time
some of those bits flip and
usually if it's just one bite here or
there it doesn't really impact
the overall file because there's like
literally millions of zeros or ones
within a
specific file and getting a couple of
them mixed up
doesn't really impact it but over a long
enough period of time you have enough of
those
flips happening that more and more of
those files become corrupted because
they don't read as they initially did
and so that's how these drives end up
dying over time is that
just given a long enough period of time
you open it up and it's like yeah the
disc
reads but all the files are corrupt
right
yeah do you have any concerns about that
happening like to a greater level
with with like respect to like
information right now
no i think there's a big enough uh
effort
towards information preservation and
there's constantly backups of pretty
much everything out there just
around i want to do a video at some
point about just how much information is
on earth
that'd be good yeah i think that's like
a library me video
yeah like stacked library books or
something sure totally
wren's library of alexandria well it's
because it's like every year
most of the information that exists in
the world was basically created that
year
rinse and repeat the year after that and
the year after that and it's like it's
crazy
how much information is constantly being
generated but so to answer your question
there are people who are working on
long-term storage solutions and i'm not
talking like a hundred years i'm talking
like
thousands of years they've got like
special thousands of years
yeah like they're coming up with ways to
like even dvds or blu-rays
do kind of uh not decompose but they
break down over time
so even like hard disks uh
are not dependable for periods longer
than like a hundred years
so yeah i mean even books you know like
books
it's hard to find a little bit older
than like 300 years old
yeah you know like to find a 300 year
old book is honestly pretty
pretty common but like an 800 year old
book
not that common because those are in
museums and no one's allowed to touch
them
right i actually i remember anytime i'm
in a
no not anytime i'm in a library but i
have been in libraries before
where i just go and my task is to find
the oldest book i can
and there's little sections in the
library it's like oh you can
smell it smells like antique book and
you start pulling out random books
like oh 1872. sweet put it back in oh
1804.
oh my god what yeah dude i went to
law school and the amount of old books
in those libraries i i think i've said
i think i've told this story somewhere
before maybe it wasn't on camera but
uh one time i was studying for the bar
exam
and i used to just take breaks like
every couple of hours to like reset my
brain
so i was just walking through the um one
of the sections
uh and uh it was a criminal law section
and i and i came across these books that
and i noticed there was something weird
about the font
that and there was like this weird s it
looked like an s
on the uh on the book cover
you know facing out yeah i was like what
is this yeah
and i open i pulled it out and i
realized that it was like uh
1800 uh year 1800
you know so like 200 years old uh
reprint
of uh english comment yeah a reprint of
english common laws from like
the 12th and 13th century
and so it had it wasn't an s it was an f
or vice versa you know how medieval you
know how uh middle
middle english f's uh look like s's
or maybe it's vice versa i guess i
honestly don't really specifically
remember but i do
yeah i'll take your word for it here let
me let me just like i do know that like
like old english has like weird
characters that english
kind of evolved over time wasn't there
also something whereas like
some characters used to actually be two
different characters and they got merged
over time
or vice versa like yeah old characters
actually ended up having to become two
different characters
double u why is it
w why is it called w
because it's because it's double u
duplive yeah and i think french
duplivae yeah it's double double double
v well the v and u used to be the same
letter
in in latin oh okay
yeah um so anyways i open up these books
and uh i start reading through them and
i and i can like barely read it because
i don't know
i don't know if you guys have ever read
old english but
it's dude almost like well ren you
have you did you live in germany norway
okay well in germany and in norway i
think
a little bit but especially in german
it's so
close to english in not in not in its
like
written origin but in its spoken origin
that if you if you read german
a lot of it if you read it phonetically
if you just like
you don't understand what it means but
you just literally say what you think it
sounds like it will sound like words in
english and a lot of times that's
actually what it is because german and
english are similar in that way
well they're germanic languages right
exactly yeah they're germanic languages
and so
the older you get into english the
further it gets
removed from like modern english and the
more conservative german again yes
and the more germanic it becomes so
you're literally like reading words that
are spelled completely differently from
from what they s how they're spelled
today but they sound the same and
those words are those words they're just
spelled totally differently
okay yeah and you can start to see like
how these languages like
split and and and divide and like
kind of go with different peoples over
time it's it's crazy that's one of the
most fascinating things that i that i
like was discovering when i was in law
school because
all these words go back to you know some
other word
there's like anglo-norman which is its
own language
which is like a mix between english and
french and there's like germanic there's
all these germanic subtexts and like
yeah it's crazy but anyway old books man
so that's how we got on this but yeah
like
i i just i sat there for like almost an
hour just like flipping through this
book oh there was a code in there
i i stumbled upon this code about uh
uh well so the way they used to do
edicts back in the day
they would like make a lie i declare yes
yeah no like literally
they they would like draw lines and then
like
write the code name and then in the next
column like write what the law is
and i came across this one that was
about like the color purple
because the color purple in england uh
you used to used to be the royal color
you couldn't wear or display the color
purple unless you were like a member of
the
royal family okay um and so it was a it
was like some sort
of edict on like the way in which like
purple was to be displayed or not
displayed
man they called dibs on a color oh yeah
they called divs on a color for sure
that's nuts also jake
it it doesn't surprise me at all that
you would procrastinate and take a break
from studying
for the bar exam by reading old english
books
ancient archived english books as a
break
from studying law dude i just get down
on that stuff man
i don't know i like i just find it
fascinating it makes you feel like you
haven't been on the earth for
like very long at all you know totally
it is fun to like connect the dots
as far back as you can go because it's
like i exist
i know that my dad exists and then his
dad had a dad
and then like he has stories about him
and then it just goes all the way back
and it's like how far can you go you
know and like tracy i think it's
something around 60 generations
is how long it's been since the dawn of
uh the written word
really yeah that's it
i mean think about it every every person
is roughly you know
30 to 100 years so 60 generations
several thousand years nothing though
when you talk about like the way that
information gets transferred from one
generation to the next
that's literally like baby baby level
well that's it's yeah it supports the
argument that physically humans today
are extremely similar to the
to how they were thousands of years ago
yeah
well that makes even more sense you know
but like it's it's it takes a lot longer
of a time frame to change
physiology you know in terms of what
you're born with
than it does to change the language that
you use
yeah well it only takes a few
generations for
for a lot of that information to evolve
it's like i mean it's like
two three generations and that's more
than that's not even
it's before the industrial revolution
yeah
well almost yeah i can so i can trace my
on my dad's side i can't do my can't do
this on my
mom's side or my my dad's mom's side but
on my dad's dad's side
we can trace that back nine generations
whoa
that's awesome yeah i know my mom or my
grandma
has been getting really into uh
genealogy and like tracing family
history and all that stuff lately
yeah it's pretty last like a decade or
so like it's pretty cool gives you
context for like
everything you know and that's that's
super important to remember like
you know i feel like in today's world
you're always required to have an answer
about something or you're always
required to like
have a way of being about things and you
know some i think sometimes it's okay to
just sit back and be like look like
you know my family's only been in this
country for a generation or two
or nine or whatever you know like i
maybe we don't know this or maybe you
know or
we've i've only been speaking this
language for
three generations in my family like i
don't know what that word means i don't
know what this
intuit to just be okay with that because
that's how else do you get better
you know you have to kind of like
find a route find it find out find a
foundation somewhere
and then build on it and build it and
then pass it on to the next generation
yeah i was actually i was having this
conversation with somebody
that like i think it was about
vfx technology that
or like filmmaking just in general which
i think
this concept can apply to many things
but
the idea of people paving the way
and filmmakers figuring things out
like for themselves at the top of their
game yeah and then like people
see that and then they take it and then
they
they improve upon it iterate on move
upon it yeah exactly and then they come
up with interviews
because someone asked me like how do you
think like
these old filmmakers are like rolling
over in their grave about like
i forget what it was and i was like no
probably not they're probably like oh
that's cool like we paved the way for
all this innovation to happen and stuff
um christian christian type saving
private ryan in the chat
what was that that's where that
conversation came from we were just like
hey
there's christian hey what's up
christian yeah just chiming in that's
where that conversation we were in that
conversation with i think some of the
black rifle guys
we were just like wow saving private
ryan really like
set the tone and then you know just the
paving the way conversation kind of
developed from there before saving
private ryan was
how were there how many films were there
that really kind of captured that sort
of tone in like brutality
i mean was that like more movies like
older movies
um i mean i guess 97
so yeah but like saving private ryan has
like this grittiness to it that i feel
like was kind of a first of its kind
well i'll tell you one thing that i know
that's paved the way for us
is today's sponsor storyblocks red knew
i was gonna do it
it's today's sponsor storyblocks guys
let me tell you about
them right now hello everyone you might
be wondering why i'm wrapped in this
beautiful emergency green screen blanket
and the answer is simple because today's
podcast is sponsored
by storyblocks they're the one-stop shop
for all your video asset needs
so whether we need b-roll after effects
templates motion graphics
sound effects or more we go over to
storybox.com
and we get what we need over here at
corridor digital the best part about
storyblocks is that they have a
virtually unlimited library of content
meaning that you can go on their site
and you're never going to use the same
thing twice with their unlimited all
access plan you guys can download as
much content as you need
put it in your video and then distribute
that video wherever you need
so whether or not you're already a
professional creator or you're just
somebody looking to start out
and improve your youtube videos that
you're just making for fun
storybox is a great resource that we've
been using for years
if you're interested head on over to
storyblocks.comcast to get started
that's storybox.com corridorcast and if
you're super cool
consider taking my head from this green
screen and putting me in hawaii
i'll wait okay just kidding back to the
podcast
and we're back um so
pave in the way um
well obviously that happened with
digital tech right when we
when when digital tech digital cameras
came out
you know and people started picking them
up but they were all janky
they couldn't expose you know they
loads like super blown out yeah they're
they're almost that dynamic range was so
low no dynamic range
you're talking about like 720p
dude 720i son 720i yeah
um and you know like it though
all the people who picked those cameras
up
whether they did it because they wanted
to for artistic purposes
or they did it because they had to
because they couldn't afford a film
camera
which is the reason why most people did
it
that absolutely that innovated
you know the filmmaking industry well
yeah i mean like i'd say probably
arguably the biggest
change to filmmaking was when canon
dropped the 5d mark
ii back in 2008 2007 somewhere in that
timeframe
it was the first like dslr that could
record
hd video directly to like a card and you
could use your
uh canon lenses because before then it
was all just like
hd like handycam essentially where you
had like the dv codec
and all the stuff and if you wanted to
use different lenses you had to use like
these crazy like
lens adapters that aim but you'd lose
like field of view
you would lose like clarity you'd always
be a little blurry
and yeah you were according to these
tapes uh it was always kind of like this
like uh it works i'm gonna make
28 days later it's great
yeah yeah but like leaning into it
though you know
yeah trying to make it cinematic but
leaning into the technology but that was
when everyone started making dslrs and
everyone started using dslrs to produce
videos because suddenly you can create
amazing quality like videos because all
it takes is just like
a camera with a decent f-stop to make
your background blurry and suddenly it
looked like the most professional video
anyone had ever made and it was so
little effort these days and for the
last 10 years or so that was
kind of like we get it we're over that
it's about everything else now but that
was kind of like the turning point in my
eyes
when it comes to like digital uh video
because
so many more people started embracing it
and so many more people were able to
iterate on those old filmmaker
techniques because there's a huge
barrier to entry before that and now
there's
not a barrier to entry and these days
even less so because everyone has the
best camera to ever exist from 10 years
ago
just in their pocket it's it's it's
insane to think about
the way that film production used to be
when you have such access to the cameras
now
which just aren't just in your pocket
because even back in the day with film
cameras
they used to before they had video
review
your your your actual cinematographer
would be sitting there whether it was a
manual role or an actual you know
motor roll and he'd roll on it and he'd
see the front motorola
[Music]
motorola is that where that comes from i
have no idea probably not okay
sorry continue so anyway he he he'd roll
on it
and then he'd see it with his viewfinder
and then he'd go yep
we got it or nope we didn't
and you'd be like that shot just cost 30
thousand dollars can we see it
no you can't you have to take the film
out in a very specific way
and have it developed and then you can
see it
and yes that's where the phrase uh get
another one for safety comes from
yeah you know it's like i think i got it
but my confidence level isn't very high
so let's just roll another one just in
case
we still do that today but today we can
obviously review it
and be like actually no we got it it's
fine right even the term rolling
watch other set terms like you don't
actually do
it's interesting because i feel like uh
the look of film
is so ingrained into our minds you know
because that's what everything was shot
on
up until you know i don't know 15
years ago i don't know 20 years ago do
you think that's the same
for for like do you think that'll be the
same for
young kids or do you think that'll
they'll have their own version of that
you know because like
digital even digital images have had a
look
over time but it's like there's like
oh this is interesting because there's a
digital look which
to me isn't is bad
compared to film which is the best
you know but there's digital
also tries to replicate film with its
color correction
you know and it's like grain and you
know a lot of the different
uh characteristics that you get from
film and film has like a nice
like roll-off of the highlights like it
had the way it handles dynamic range is
different like fundamentally different
than how a digital sensor processes
highlights
right and so a lot of cameras have been
trying to emulate that sort of like roll
off of highlights
that film has and it's all everything at
it's always just been trying to emulate
that look because
that's what everyone has always
associated with the film look
and like the digital cameras are
certainly cheaper and more
widely accessible um
and they're you know i feel like for a
certain time and maybe still now like
a lot of people are trying to get still
get to that film look
um but now there's a digital look
you know that uh i know like what is it
david fincher shoots all of his stuff on
like red and
it's all digital his stuff looks so good
it's great it's not like
it's not like absolutely it looks
phenomenal but like even the thing
even the thing we shot the other day
with the halloween video with black
rifle
like we shot that on black magic
the 6k yeah the 6km 6k or 4k we had both
out
oh it was both um i
i honestly sam was shooting so i didn't
we had we had both uh one yeah
one was on a handheld i think the gimbal
was a 6k
yeah it was yeah and
you know the thing that obviously the
black magics look real nice
you know they they've done a good job
sort of giving that initial
emulation of film
but the thing that i think take took
that piece and made it look even nicer
was the lighting
yeah the lighting is supposed to like it
really comes down to your lighting
really at the end because if you look at
old films
where the lighting's not that good
it doesn't look that nice you know like
even in the 60s and 70s when they would
it didn't have like some sometimes they
didn't have it you know and they were
kind of
they were trying to do it on the cheap
and stuff well there's a reason
yeah there's a reason why like the
lighting department has always been
a huge part of filmmaking right
oh man yeah i mean with i mean i got so
okay i got theories on this
so basically the shooting something on
film where you have that grain
there's kind of like a a a veil
of there's there's a veil there's just a
veil
between you and the footage and it makes
it feel
more magical um more like a dream
more like it's in your head when you're
watching something
and when you take that veil away it's
just like
real life crispy clean and that veil
and that like imagination kind of
disappears a little bit
maybe subconsciously at least that's the
that's my theory
see i think that comes from lighting
because if you look at
if like look at our lighting right now
right this is
this is obviously we have like horrible
digital lighting right now
but like even if we were sitting in the
same room together
you you wouldn't be you wouldn't have
the same lighting that you
usually have in a regular piece with
nice lighting
you know it's because think about it in
your in your consciousness
in your in your everyday when you walk
into a room
and the sunlight is hitting a room in a
certain way
like maybe it's like sunset or it's like
evening
you know and the sun hasn't quite gone
down or it's morning
and the sun is like off and it's softer
and it's maybe coming through a window
in a certain way and creating
like actual frame lines that are guiding
your
eye the first thing that you notice
is the lighting in the room yeah but in
a nice
in a piece that has nice cinematography
with good lighting
that's every shot immediately
i think there's also a subconscious
where you see something that has nice
lighting and you don't
know why it looks good because you
expect it because it's within four
corners on a frame that you're watching
you expect it to look good
but you don't necessarily know why and i
think that's a huge reason why
because it's not like you walk around in
your everyday life and everyone has
perfect rim lights
and fills you know just when you're like
in conversation with people that's
that's just movies like every literally
everything in a movie is
over dramatized in order to look its
best like hair
makeup lighting the camera the story
the characters like everything that
every little piece that goes into making
a movie
is maxed out and it feels like a movie
it's not real life it's a movie
you know and like this is like this was
the hardest concept for me to grasp
because i'm like no you want it to be
like real life like real life is like
super realistic and you want to be like
that
and it has to be like that it's like
well no i mean
real life isn't this traumatic for most
people
well why you don't make videos about
real life every day because it's not
it's interesting you know everyone can
relate to it
what you want to see is something that's
different or like a new story or like a
challenge
you know or a success or a failure that
someone goes through
rather than just like oh yeah this is my
commute to work
no story you just hold on somebody for
20 minutes
where like they they have like perfect
lighting on their commute to work
like that well good lighting transcends
the camera that you use you know it's
like
totally like really really good looking
video footage just on like a gopro
if you have great great lighting yeah
whereas you can
shoot that same exact scene on like a
red camera and just remove all your
lights and it looks awful
right yeah it's like when you you know
pull out your iphone and you're like
oh man this shot looks good this looks
really good and it's because probably
because of the lighting
so i this is what i wanted to say about
film and digital
like there are old films that do not
look good because they have bad lighting
now that so it doesn't there's not
necessarily a one-to-one like if you
just put it on film it's gonna look
better
but if you look at films in the 80s and
90s
where you're sort of at the epitome of
the the art of actual filmmaking
not like digital storytelling but like
shooting stories on film
and the movie industry also like
economically
yeah the 90s was peak technology and
film processing what exactly it was peak
technology for
for what all the tools that they were
using at the time like
before digital came along and it's late
80s early 90s
terminator 2 yes you get these freaking
beautiful beautiful films like
because they had the money they could
justify the expense
and they knew exactly what to do with
the technology now i will say
a well-shot piece in digital
has its own look for sure but i think in
terms of like
aesthetic beauty like they they both
hold up with today's digital cameras
now it's a different look so it's it
comes down to personal preference
it's like if you like the film look
better then you're obviously gonna feel
like the films of that era are gonna
look prettier because
that's an aesthetic thing but in terms
of like
fundamentals you know framing like the
fall off
the lighting the scope the shape of the
scene like i
i feel i still feel like we're getting
that yeah i mean well you talk about
like blade
or go ahead go ahead wren no i have a
blade runner yeah it's great i honestly
think we're at a point now where
there isn't really a difference between
classic film
look and digital look like i feel like
digital has gotten so good these days
that it just comes down to
the aesthetic preference of whoever's uh
directing or color grading
you know who's mastering blade runner is
that was shot on
gorgeous i think uh that's ari alexa
mini was it okay uh ari alexa xt
series almost no one shoots on film
anymore it's like
10 years ago i was like wow this
person's shot on digital all right
social network cool nolan and uh
there are a few holdouts nolan's
probably the most famous like
film hold out what's no what's his name
god dang kill bill
oh tarantino yeah he's he he
every film is is on film for him
um but yeah i don't know i feel like
you'll get like these random ones that
are like oh a shot on film that's
awesome
it's nice to see that like that callback
um
but yeah at this point it's like you
have roger deakins who shot
blade runner and it's all in the alexa
which people love the alexa because it
has the high dynamic range yeah because
of the dynamic range is maxed out right
um and then you put in the hands of a
master like roger deakins and it's like
dude it doesn't matter
yeah but you're right there there is an
aesthetic difference there i think like
generally that still exists and
you know there is that idea that people
are trying to emulate the film look and
that's perhaps why
blade runner the new one like did so
well in all those categories and it was
so acclaimed
for all those things because it
maintained that
look um but well yeah
well uh jake you mentioned earlier like
you're you're like all right
what is that going to be for the next
generation of like what are they going
to try to continue to emulate from what
we're doing now and
right it's like i i have no idea what
that could possibly be but
you know like frame rate for instance 24
frames per second
was became a thing because that was the
slowest frame rate that filmmakers
100 years ago could achieve without it
the video being like actually like
stuttery and flickery
yeah um and because that saves you the
most amount of frames
it gives you the most amount of actual
footage to run
because it's going as slow as possible
without looking janky
because if it is to go faster then
you're just wasting wasting frames
frames but like that has become a thing
now today we can easily
upload a video at 180 frames per second
for anyone to just consume at that frame
rate
which no one does because there's not
really good mediums for that
long story um my point is that
we still hold to that 24 frames per
second look because
there's all of the psychology behind it
now you know it's like
that stuttery that like it's not
stuttery but it definitely is
not remotely as smooth as say 30 frames
per second which gives it like a little
bit more of a a little bit more uh
like a realistic look it gives it that
soap opera look right
it's the whole video the reality yeah
the home video
yeah and maybe so maybe that's part of
it where it's like all right we could do
30fps we could do that now so we're
doing it
and now everyone associates that look
with what
tv shows were doing and distinctly in
their heads like that is not what movies
are doing movies look like this
so there's still like a definite
difference between that
i love 60 frames per second video it's
very smooth it's very temporally high
resolution but it is not
the movie look you know there's a time
and place for
high frame rate upgrades if you put some
awesome footage like aerial photography
or what have you on a large tv
it's 60 frames a second in 4k without a
bad
compression ratio but like a nice
compression like that
looks like you're there it's like
you know well that was why i wanted to
do mario skate you know like back in the
day when we did that video that was the
60 frames per second video
and the reason why i wanted it to i
paired the idea with that frame rate is
because
this is like a race you know going
through town so there's a lot of moving
stuff uh the ground is moving the wall
the background the walls are moving
everything's moving
uh at a really high speed and that you
just
you see that better at a higher frame
rate and that was why i specifically
wanted to shoot that video at a high
frame rate
um yeah no i remember that but like just
like a drama
it like i feel like there's a bit of a
barrier between what uh
your what's it called the suspension of
disbelief
yeah if it becomes more real suddenly
you're like wow this is
real and kind of like dislocated from
the drama yeah instead of watching two
people
have an argument and internalizing what
their argument is
and like how you feel about it based
upon what you previously saw
you're sitting there at the table with
them and you're like oh this is kind of
awkward
should i not be here right now but i
don't think that that's because of
the frame rate being slower or faster
it's just because of what we've been
ingrained to
uh consume you know like our experiences
are defined by these things and now that
it's different it reacting
if we if they settle on 60 frames per
second for movies 100 years ago
we'd be looking at 24fps and like wow
i'm just getting a headache from how
stuttery this is
yeah this isn't a movie totally i want
that traditional filmmaking look yeah
yeah i don't know i wonder because like
our eyes it's all based off our eyes
like our eyes are the like the truth the
ground truth right so like that's what
it's all based off of is what
how we see i don't know the frame rate
of what we see it's very high it's
complicated
it's it it honestly changes between like
80 frames per second
and like 300 frames per second it's
variable multiple times a second
depending on adrenaline right
probably yeah how does that how does
that sorry you're gonna have to explain
a little biology there
like how do you do my best how do you
equate frame rate to
human so it's you can't think of human
perception and frame rate that was a
false
um okay uh metaphor for lack of a better
way to say it right yeah there's a
conversion process we're not
seeing our brain is basically capturing
images as a stream of
things happening and if you have a shot
of adrenaline or something happen or you
need to focus your brain can can process
more images faster and so you're
you're actually seeing in a higher frame
rate you're just
you're i mean no that's exactly what
you're doing you're basically
it's not you're not seeing things in
slow motion you're just able to process
more frames in the same amount of time
yeah time is moving slower because
you're getting
your your your brain is processing so
much in
uh what seems like a smaller amount of
time and the only thing we have to
equate it to is frame rate so that's why
we say that
yeah and it's like and again i am not
remotely enough of an expert to talk
about this confidently but that's kind
of how it works is that
there isn't like an exact refresh rate
and i probably don't even have the
numbers right but i do know there it is
variable and it's a pretty
large variability yeah now that makes
sense i mean
you know we've all been in moments of
like turmoil or danger
and you pro you you process that
way faster
i remember one time um
ryan you know that giant bridge in
pasadena right by the freeway the one
goes over okay
so i remember i was a wit i forget who
else who i was with but i was hopping a
chain-link fence
and it may have been you ren i may have
been with you but i was hoping a
chain-link fence and i climbed the top
of it and i like had my backpack on
and there's like cars on the freeway
going down on the left and i'm hopping
this chain-link fence to go
hop into like a grassy field to
eventually get on the sidewalk
and i hop it and i'm like oh god don't
clip my legs
i managed to get over the fence and as i
was
hurtling over the fence i look up and i
see a branch
like a jagged witchy branch like
coming right branch yeah right at my eye
and it like within the split second i
remember
seeing that branch having it fly towards
me my vision went
like black because i basically just
freaking like karate chopped it
and went and i landed it i was like oh
my god
and i thought about like that happened
so fast yeah but
i remember seeing it like
there was these different frames of
information and i remember
like seeing it seeing it closer chopping
it
and then like seeing the ground going
like
and then oh that was intense yeah
because our brains can
can can change the the timing of a
memory
so when you think back on it you have
more information from that one
second of time that you can slow down as
a memory
yeah but when you're actually consuming
that reality
as it's becoming a memory it's happening
in real time as fast as you just sitting
on a couch watching a movie
well that's the whole thing of why
you know humans are i mean remarkable
but obviously like
you think about the way that you just
even normalize
time itself that's all like the
the way that's like oh that seemed
faster than that seemed so fast
or that happens so slow that's all
that's all
based upon this the intaking of
information
based upon like a normalized chemical
state
in your brain that most of us you know
that's relatively the same across most
of us
because i don't know if you've ever done
mushrooms or acid
but those things
completely marijuana does this too if
you take too much of it like it
completely changes your perception
of how fast or slow time is happening
interesting and that's that's not
because like
time is happening slower or faster it's
happening at the same rate it's always
happening at
but what you're processing
is happening differently than what
you're used to
yeah it feels like it's so there's
there's moments
you know where you'll be like far out
dude yeah exactly
there's moments where you'll be like oh
my god i just had the craziest thought
and it and
it'll feel like you were gone you know
for like a long amount of time and then
you come back and it's like a minute
later or you're still like
doing the same thing that you were doing
before or like you know
now that you need mind-altering drugs in
order for that to happen that's just an
example
you know i got maybe it's because like
you're trying to
you're you're so focused like it's like
when um when i rode motorcycles
um for like a two year period which was
just the best i miss it so much
but when i was riding motorcycles you
could only focus on
riding the motorcycle and nothing else
else you'd die
um so i think that's why people say it's
like meditation is because
really it is because meditation at the
end of the day is just focusing on one
task for a long amount
for an extended amount of time so you're
focusing on the motorcycle and writing
you know when you come out of it it's
like when i when i come out of a vfx
shot and i'm like well i was in that for
like
the last two hours yeah yeah you're like
man
i felt like no time passed at all
but really all this time passed or it's
the other way around it's like really
interesting
the same thing happens in an edit yeah
it's in the zone when you get the zone
yeah when you're in the zone on an edit
and you're just kind of like
you know you're moving through it and
you're picking shots and you're like
putting scenes together you're putting
reactions together
it's like hours can go by oh yeah you
look up and you'll be like oh
that was i've been doing this for two
hours
yeah when i um when i do these like vfx
streams on the weekend
i'll go for i think my longest one was
like five hours and 45 minutes
and i was just sitting at this computer
like working on something like cg
modeling
do you play like tran uh trans house
music
while you do this like is that your five
hours would be too much
i mean honestly five hours is too much
of anything um
with musically not apparently not
apparently it's enough for you
to do vfx tutorials that's a good point
oh i mean i mean like
music wise um after five hours
i will be like whatever i'm listening to
it's too much yeah but it's gotta stop
yeah and then i'm freaking talking the
whole time and it's my throat starts
hurting yeah
anyway that's a side tangent but okay so
i wanted to get back to one more thing
and clear
you you don't have to talk about this if
you don't want to
yeah there there's there's two things
a there's something that happened in
your life recently you can talk about
that if you want
uh and then uh b uh
i think that kind of leads into what you
were talking about at the beginning when
we started this episode which was like
you know you're doing this 5 a.m thing
you're focusing on self-improvement
and then one of the things you also said
was like you're you're reading rich dad
poor dad
now there's another thing that you're
just
you're just going through right now you
know related to
a square shaped thing that you know
this is a square space segue no no it's
not christmas
just like clint say it say it yeah i'm
just trying to talk if you want to talk
about it we can talk about it but
there's two really cool things that i'd
love
to just explore for a little bit so
okay um well it's not
quite official um
but uh
you talking about the box yeah the box
oh okay
okay no no i did get engaged
hey congratulations you got engaged
you're gonna be
married dude yeah
no way to do that casually quite
official
okay yeah so sorry i apologize i was
speaking in context there for
just case clinton didn't want to talk
about this but uh
there's so ren you thought
we were talking about him getting
engaged
and then him saying it's not quite
official no i i was being a little uh
facetious there i know both of the
things you're talking about okay
yeah and then yeah by the way before we
move on
like my friend in college did the exact
same thing that you just did he's like
oh yeah
yeah we got engaged yeah yeah it's funny
i don't know it's like
we've been living together for the last
year you know so it feels like
we're basically married you know yeah
and i honestly
the number one question i would always
get after i got married was like so
do you feel any different it's like no i
feel the exact same
it's the exact same we're still living
together we're still doing our
stupid things that we do every day
nothing's different when you get married
if you've already been living together
that's kind of what you want though not
complaining
i think you should live i mean there's
different opinions out there about this
but i think you should live with
somebody before you get married to him
because that you gotta kind of you know
you need to know that yeah that's an
interesting one
definitely because like i was raised the
other the opposite way
like you know you got to get married
right before you do anything
and then you join houses right and then
you live together
exactly but yeah um so and then the next
thing that happened is you're you're in
the process
of uh buying uh a house
or in the process of you know searching
for a home i don't know where you're at
in that
house i thought you were talking about
boxes
[Laughter]
so yeah it's exciting there's these two
sort of monumental things in a man's
life that you're kind of going through
right now
like you know marriage in a house like
is that
is that does that factor into like this
whole
5 a.m phase or um
i it's not the reason why i'm doing the
5 a.m thing um yeah
and hopefully it's not a phase hopefully
it'll be a lifelong thing
but i'm always just trying to get better
like that's that's my thing is i'm
always trying to just like
learn as much as i can and get better at
what i do
because i i truly think that as like we
go further into the future and
technology gets crazier and crazier and
gets
cooler and cooler we're gonna lose
our patience like just we don't we won't
have patience
for anything and our discipline and i
think those things will go away pretty
quick
finish your point already god i don't
have patience for this
lingerer
um yeah there's like forced patients you
know
like sometimes you have to become
patient because you don't have a choice
yeah like i got a lot of discipline but
there's also self-imposed
discipline and self-imposed patience
which i think is
you know more constructive ultimately
yeah i'm basically just like i mean the
cool thing for me is like waking up at
5 45 every morning is
i never like ever will ever again
be like oh i have to wake up so early
for a shoot it's just
normal like it's just this is the time i
wake up and
early call time is not a big deal so
it's preparing me for
you know if i can make my life just a
little bit hard on purpose
yeah then i think i'll grow from that
and i'll be like preparing myself for
any difficult task that comes in the
future
honestly i think the harder thing than
waking up at that time
is having the discipline to go to bed
early enough oh
dude yes that that
freaking that dude um that's why when
when we were in texas for the travel
production i don't
have like it'd be so lame
if i was like you know what guys i'm not
gonna play smash bros with you i'm not
gonna chill in the jacuzzi
and i'm going to bed right after dinner
that would just be the worst
man um i can't i can't do that yeah
um but it's a little easier yeah
yeah it was kind of janky but yeah i
mean i that's
that's been my biggest thing is that
like that's the thing that i try to work
on most is that
just try to go to bed earlier it's so
hard for me personally like i
i can easily stay up all night tonight
if i wanted yeah i want to see the
sunrise i can easily stay up to see it
no big deal barely even have to try so i
i'm
constantly finding myself like oh i
should probably try to get some sleep
now it's
three yeah as long as you get those
seven or nine hours
i know and that's that's the thing is
that is and it's been kind of helped
working from home in that regard i can
stay up later and still get plenty of
sleep because i could just wake up at
ten
yeah but uh i have been making a bigger
effort to try to be like
basically winding down ready to sleep by
midnight and that has been leading to me
waking up earlier throughout the week
and i find myself enjoying my days
better
it's just so hard to have the discipline
to go to sleep early
dude i i mean i remember those mornings
that we'd have ren where we'd one wheel
into the office
[Music]
so i mean i still do it yeah for sure um
so those mornings for me i'd get up and
i'd go to a hot yoga class and then i
would one wheel with you to work
and those that like that those mornings
were the best mornings
ever and i'm like why don't i do this
more often like i feel so much better
when i do it this way than when i just
like
roll out of bed and i'm like oh god i
gotta get to work you know and i'm just
like
stressed yeah and i'm like oh i never
want to wake up stressed
like waking up stress is probably like
one of the worst things ever so
doing the early morning thing has helped
so much i just take the morning slow
um do it do it my way and
and have like three and a half
hours before i have to start work it's
a lot of time yeah no that's awesome
that's that's actually
since i've moved out here you know it's
nine o'clock where i'm at
oh god that that's right and so like
it's been nice in that sense like i
i i can i have a little bit more time
for myself
to focus on some things and like you
know get get
whatever it might be my kids or my
personal whatever
you know to get that sort of situated
get my workout in whatever
before i have to be like mentally
transitioning over to focus on
all the other things that we're working
on day in day out because you're on our
schedule
yeah because i'm on pacific my work is
on pacific time
you know my like my like actual creative
work focus is on pacific time but then
my my life is on
central time dude that reminds me about
when i was uh
on night shift like intentionally
because jenna was on night shift we were
living together this was during that
like weird sabbatical where i wasn't
working for corridor because i was
working on my harry potter film and then
i was working on a couple other things
yeah uh between when i finished doing
behind the scenes and when i started
working on
uh quarter digital main channel stuff i
had like the sabbatical and jenna was
working night shifts so she would you
know
go to bed wake up you know in the
evening go to work
come home and then go to bed you know in
the morning
and sleep through the day so i was like
i will get to see her more frequently if
i'm on her schedule so i was
i was basically like sleeping through
the day working all night
and then having a beer at like seven or
eight in the morning like ah
good day damn ren
uh that's already it was not good
because after a while i realized this is
awful because i was having
zero interaction with any other people
because
nothing's open at three in the morning
right there are no restaurants that you
can just go to
yeah uh when i was living alone here in
l.a i would go to eat at restaurants
just because that was
one way to have human interaction
because i was living alone
i hadn't moved here yet yeah yeah i i
guess what i'm saying is
operating on someone else's uh
time zone is is an interesting thing
granted i literally just
that's an extreme example yeah it's like
that's way more extreme than just two
hours later but that's the movie version
i don't know why it just reminds me i'm
not saying it's the same thing
that's the movie version
cool guys well um clint congratulations
man
once again i mean thank you so much yeah
it's a long time coming
uh i can't wait for you to open up a
guest room so i can come and
invade your space and uh wait for you to
tell me kindly that i should
that i've overstayed my welcome oh man
it's gonna be great that's a rough
conversation just thinking about that is
already giving me anxiety i'm like
hey man what do you want to do today
i gotta work no that's awesome dude um
so congrats on that
and uh yeah um
more uh more journeys more discoveries
uh both personally
and uh within the creative craft so
always good to hear
um always good to hear from you here man
absolutely yeah it's fun doing these
chats with you guys at the end of the
day it's a nice little like end of the
day
kind of cool down whoa
and now we're just doing sound effects
okay should i play an outro again let's
hear it
all right what did we say at the
beginning of this podcast
that clinton was here ren was here
clinton was here ren was here clinton
was here
red was here and jake was too
clinton was here he had a beer friend
was here
and christian was here too but he only
said one or two
things i think he literally said a total
of nine words
oh you counted later
oh y'all words no 11.
all right see you guys later cool peace
guys
thanks for watching